wow it's just nine days nine days away
right
unreal what is that nine is it right
falls days is it
is he number nine nine nick falls days
number nine like full stays uh away from
the
kansas city chiefs kicking things off
against the uh houston texans
on thursday night football and the man
who called nick foles
philly special in that super bowl in
minnesota a couple of years ago and now
going to call yet another season of
sunday night football alongside our good
friend al michaels is our good friend
chris collinsworth how are you chris
what's happening rich i'm excited how
about you
yeah me too i i think for so long we
were all afraid that it just
wasn't going to happen right you know
you're just kind of sitting there going
ah this is
really going to happen and you know the
cove and stuff
and everything was was happening and uh
by the way have you had a covet test yet
have you have you had the full
i've had the full
turn sideways then vertically then
sideways and vertically again have you
had that thing yet
i have chris and i share here on this
show and it's also very important for
uh men of uh our age to do such a thing
i had the covet 19 swab all the way up
to your brain
colonoscopy double whammy so i had that
going for me chris
i had that as well there you go
parallel university brother
[Music]
it's unbelievable right i mean thank god
they've got the the
saliva test now going so
i i can't wait to hear some al's stories
oh my gosh um so are you are you
planning on being
at the games is that the plan for you
and al to physically be
at each sunday night spot chris yeah
yeah i don't i mean i guess we could do
it if we
had to do it um
i i i i it would be it would be hard
you know because i i can't even really
explain i mean you you would understand
this you called games you know what i'm
talking about
but it's a i mean my setup kind of looks
like uh
i'm flying an airplane right i've got
sort of
you kind of get trained to different
things and
if it's a if it's a pass play then i
look at this if it's a run play i look
at this if it's
bad and then how we time out replays and
communicate it back to fred and drew and
and then you know kind of listen to what
al is saying but also
trying to talk to fred and you know how
how would you
do that from uh like your basement like
i was talking to john smalls and he was
saying that they
i mean he's in his basement calling the
game and his partner's in his basement
calling the game and the
producers somewhere else you know
calling the game
it's just i i don't know how you do it
mm-hmm
it's just a fascinating year and we're
going to see how it all plays out
with wins and losses um very shortly
starting in nine days from now
kansas city and houston but i i you know
normally
we do start with the super bowl champ
and i do want to talk with you about
them in a second but
this is uh as we all know uh been
dominated
our world for the last 20 years in the
conversation about brady and belichick
you and i had a fascinating moment
sitting and watching the two of them
together on the set of the nfl 100
all-time team show
interestingly enough taped out of order
that was the first segment that we
recorded was the two of them on the set
how do you think they will both fare
without each other
this year chris um pretty well
i i mean i really do i i you know
tom brady is going to have offensive
weapons that he
didn't have at least last year
at his disposal in tampa they you know
have three tight ends that can play with
anybody and
you know goblin and evans and i mean
it's it's going to be exciting to see
what he can do in that
and the other part of him that you know
you know the hard part is it's the first
time he's had to learn a new offense
right
and and so that's going to be at the
very least it's going to be a different
language i don't think it'll be
new plays i don't think it'll be
something he can't handle but just
you know being able to wink in a nod
with guys that you've been playing with
for 10 years the edelmans of the world
thank goodness he's got
gronkowski back there with him one more
time um
but i i really do feel like that this is
going to be a test
for tom especially early on especially
going against drew brees in an offense
that has been together now
uh for quite some time so um
[Music]
i'm looking forward to that i think i'm
more looking forward
to watching new england play because new
england is
kind of just such an interesting case
study no matter how you slice in a
thousand different ways they're just
such an
interesting case study and on how they
continue to win we've seen belichick
win without brady in the past i i often
thought that one time that brady was
suspended for those four games that and
he started out
3-0 that he was probably as mad
losing that fourth game as he was any
game he ever coached in his life
even with his third string quarterback
having to play
because you know there's a point of
pride i mean these guys
have heard all that noise all those
years
uh oh is it belichick is it brady is in
the obvious answer is of course it was
both of them
and so now for the first time we're
seeing
that split up and as a fan is a just a
human being
it's just interesting isn't it you can
say anything you want maybe it's not
relevant in your mind maybe it's not it
but it makes this football season
really interesting and i love the start
of this one
i love the fact that we haven't seen any
of these teams play in pre-season we
haven't seen any of these rookies or
free agents
with their current team it's like the
start of college football
and there's just this great unknown i'm
never prepared for opening day where i
haven't seen an
ounce of current tape of that team
that's been put together
so i i just think in many ways this is
the most exciting start to an nfl season
that we've ever seen i agree chris and
and you want to talk about interesting
that that's why i mean certainly with
the cowboys having mike mccarthy now at
the helm the nfc west is vastly
different and also improved we could
talk about yannick and gawkway now
in uh the nfc north and what that means
with aaron rodgers being just an
inch shy in the regular season last year
being the one seed coming back now and
then you've got the defending super bowl
champs in the uh kansas city chiefs
along with
big ben returning from injury and yet i
led with brady belichick with you for
for a reason and the thing that's really
interesting to me
is bruce arians this week i don't know
if you saw complaining about how bad the
offense looked in practice said that he
thought all 11 guys out there were too
busy reading their newspaper clippings
which i don't believe brady's heard
in quite some time even with belichick
and on the opposite side
when was the last time you heard
belichick say that this is what he had
to say on sirius
xm uh nfl radio about cam newton go
forward
extremely hard worker nobody works
harder than cam does he's here early he
stays late
and he works very hard you know some
players like to work on things that
they're good at
you know like if you're strong on a
bench press you just keep throwing more
weight on the bench but cam's the type
of player that
you know works on things that he's not
as good at and really tries to improve
uh on a daily basis and and that's
something that
know i really respect about him like
that's not easy for players really any
of us to do is something
look at something that we're not very we
don't feel like we're very good at or
it's not one of our strengths
and put extra time into it when you know
it's a natural
tendency is to you know do things you're
good at i mean i heard that chris and i
thought to myself that obviously his
relationship with brady didn't
you know didn't seem to bring it about
but if he had said that once
in the last 10 years publicly about tom
would tom still be in new england
i literally thought that sort of stuff
you know yeah
i mean we're going to psychoanalyze that
relationship
long after both of them are dead you
know i mean let's face it that's a
historic
moment in time in the national football
league what those guys were able to do
together
but it didn't totally stun me
um you know that they they went after
cam because
we did the game last year with lamar
jackson
kind of running through those guys and
you remember at the time i think the
patriots were undefeated i think they
were 8-0
and their defense was setting historic
pace yes
for points allowed and lamar jackson
went through him like a goose i mean it
was
unbelievable and it it's you know i was
an
option quarterback in high school and my
first year of college
and when the option play works
it is unstoppable when it really really
works
because you have to remember and
especially when the quarterback runs the
ball
so when you're adding that extra player
so what happens in an ordinary play the
the quarterback turns around hands the
ball off to the running back
and he stands and cheers for his guys
after that so it's basically
10 on 11 right but now
when you have a quarterback that can run
like lamar like cam
and you have 10 blockers on 11 defenders
the math changes and now when you also
have to have that extra defender in the
box to play that run
and now you've got nothing but man
coverage working on the outside
the passing game changes so
after watching the success that
cam had had in the past against the
patriots and after watching lamar
last year against his record-breaking
defense
uh it really didn't surprise me that
maybe
that's somewhere in the back of his mind
because you know the whole thing with
tim tebow
and all of that as well is was he did he
know
as a defensive minded coach that if they
really got that right
and they really learned how to play that
style uh with this sort of precision
that the patriots do everything
you know could they then create this
unstoppable offense that was the
complete antithesis of what they had
with tom brady i mean
to me all that stuff is just so darn
interesting
and i can't wait to watch it i think we
get them the second week of the season
chris collinsworth here on the rich
eisen show from sunday night football
um you got kansas city right in front of
you against houston what a heck of an
opener coming up in a couple of
thursdays
i want to throw something at you that's
not x's and o's
um and this might be overthinking it
because we've had nothing but time to
think
but the concept of a super bowl hangover
usually means players and coaches are
fetid wherever they go for weeks and
months
and they uh get i guess uh complacent
or there's been just so much going on
that when they get back to work that it
feels like a grind
but this year there hasn't been any of
that because of covid
i'm wondering if you you you put that in
the hopper
plus patrick mahomes is young and just
dynamic and paid and all the other guys
are paid
and happy and um and andy reid
wants to go back-to-back probably worse
than anybody else to just keep this
thing going
that the chiefs are favorites just for
this alone what do you think
i i think they're favorites for the most
part because they
they didn't have great change you know
that
as you look at the beginning of this
football season and i think we all have
to
anticipate the possibility anyway
that we don't make it all the way
through 16 games i mean
right anything is possible right in this
football season so
it looks like we're going to get to the
beginning of the year
short of you know we don't know with the
social justice movement you know could
there be some sort of stoppage there and
you know i i just don't know about all
that kind of stuff
but i think when you take what they have
on the offensive side
and the continuity that they have there
and then you look at what the defense
was able to do
under steve spagnola on the in the the
last
six seven games of the season on into
the playoffs
i mean they were one of the best
defenses in football you want to go back
to the super bowl
the reason they won the super bowl was
because their defense was able to make
those fourth quarter stands
and really hold down a very dynamic
offensive football team when everything
was on the line i mean for patrick
mahomes
honestly for three quarters that may
have been one of the worst games that
i've ever seen him play
and then in the fourth quarter when it
was all on the line
of course he did what the greatest of
the great players do
so i i think the continuity is going to
give this team some advantages uh going
into the season so yeah a worthy
favorite i i'll tell you a team though
that i would keep an eye on this okay
that not many people are talking about i
think almost everybody is going kansas
city baltimore
uh as far as the two favorites and that
makes the most sense right baltimore had
the best record and
kansas city is the world champs but
pittsburgh
you look at what pittsburgh did
defensively last year that team damn
near made the playoffs
with people off the street named duck
playing quarterback last year
and and when you think about what they
did defensively
i mean they hunkered down defensively
they were something else
defensively and i don't know that much
about tommy john's surgery but i
i've heard that there are some people
that can't wait to have tommy john's
surgery if they're a pitcher because
they come back
stronger than what they left and
everything i've been reading about ben
is that it seems like he's throwing the
ball as well
if not better than ever because his arm
for the first time in years and years
and years
isn't hurting him so if you take
what is if that defense stays solid and
there's no reason to think that they
won't
and ben returns on the offensive side
i mean the north is going to be a heck
of a fist fight
for this football season i love it chris
collinsworth here on the rich eisen show
before i let you go
the best team in the nfc coming into
2020
is um
i i i i really fell in love with san
francisco last year
and i i picked them to win the super
bowl
and i was so smug sitting up in the
stands just feeling like i
i swear rich i never i was like i told
everybody this is what was gonna happen
they were gonna yeah it's just one of
those you know i didn't really
say it out loud i just was kind of
sitting there going you are such a
genius
and then it just all went so south so
i'm still a big fan of the 49ers i don't
like some of the injuries
that they've had and i'm scared to death
to even say this
but the dallas cowboys at least on the
offensive side to me
feel like they are just loaded up i love
cd lamb
coming out of the draft i just really
did and mari cooper
is one of the best one-on-one route
runners gallup's a really nice player
elliot's you know we know what he's
going to be and pollard is
a guy that i think will be a much bigger
factor this year in the backup role
maybe as a receiver
uh coming out you know a little bit of
it depends on
how well they do without travis
frederick there at the center position
but but i i just feel like that this is
a team that really does
have a chance now how long does it take
they're the
flip side of what we talked about with
some of these other teams getting off to
a hot start i don't think they'll get
off to a great start because they're a
new team new coach
new coordinator on the defensive side
with mike nolan's i think it might take
a little while
but i see no reason that the cowboys
can't be really tough coming into
wow you want dallas and i love the
caveat i hate to say it
you know because everybody in the world
either loves or hates dallas but
i i look at them i love teams building
around their quarterback and their
receivers and i i just you just get the
feeling that
that dax gotten a little bit of money
now and
yet he still didn't get the contract so
he's got a little bit of that chip
on his shoulder and man i watched every
pass this guy through
uh this past season and i'm just going
man
he's a lot better than people give him
credit for and he's that right blend he
can he can run that read option
well enough he's not gonna you know he
can escape the stacks
um if they get the only thing i worry
about the offensive line you know
are they anywhere close at center and
left guard
to what they used to be and will they
get the production out of the tight end
position you know
will blake jarlin take that next step
on on that but and hopefully they hold
up at the cornerback position
you know those are the things you got to
worry about with the cowboys but
man they got leighton van der smith or
two
hot shot and also
also linebackers i mean uh demarcus
lawrence just gotta go
ever since griffin i mean it's got it
all and
there's no reason and they also have
their reason for them not i know and
they also have
maybe one of the most fascinating
players of 2020 alton smith
who was such a beast rushing the passer
um who has had so much trouble staying
sober
um he's back and if he is alden smith of
the
uh days of the niners look out
that's i mean he averaged almost a sack
a game
in his first three years something like
that he was
unblockable unblockable so who knows
i i honestly i cannot wait to get this
thing started i
just can't wait i'm i'm getting ready
for
four different teams and i've basically
forgotten about the rest of the league
so i get lost in my own little world
this time of year
uh but i i can't remember a time that i
felt this
amped up about the beginning of the
season and i know there's a million
things
uh to be worried about in this world in
2020 which is
the worst year in the history of my
lifetime anyway and there's so many
different things that we need to solve
as a society and
i get all that but i also get that as
depressing as the first
half has been i'm hoping the nfl and the
nfl players with
what they're doing to try and improve
our society and our culture as a whole
uh just lead us out of it and at the end
of 2020
and i'm excited about it plus one chris
thanks for the call
always love our chats congrats on that
uh you know
all of us together with nfl films and
belichick and bill
uh the nfl 100 all-time team winning a
couple of emmys that was uh
again well i'll always bring it up to
you because it really was a top five
moment for me so
just wanted to say thanks and congrats
very very cool indeed it's always a
pleasure richard right back
always that's chris collinsworth pro
football focus is uh of course
uh one of his focuses as well it's
amazing it's amazing
helps make sense of a lot of things
uh watching the nfl hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here